-Denzel, I know you played --
back in the day,
you played basketball
at Fordham University
here in New York City.
So, tonight, I want to challenge
you to a random object shootout.
Here's how this works.
You brought your own squash.
This is great.
-No.
-No, no, I gave this to you.
Here's how this works.
We're going to take turns
trying to shoot random objects
into that hoop.
The objects we're shooting
tonight are...
a butternut squash...
[ Light laughter ]
...an official skateboard
of "Roman J. Israel, Esq."...
[ Light laughter ]
...a bowl of cranberry sauce.
The one with the berries.
Not the one from the can, yeah.
A file full of legal documents.
[ Light laughter ]
Because it's from the movie,
you see.
And the money ball.
This is worth two points.
A VHS copy of the classic
Spike Lee "He Got Game"
starring Denzel Washington.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, Denzel.
-A-A-And before we start,
because I may never get this
opportunity again.
I just want to thank
the Academy.
-No, no, that's not --
-No, oh, okay,
all right, all right.
-You go this way, this is the
line here, and you'll go first.
ready?
-No, you first.
No pressure.
-What do you mean me first?
-You first.
-But you're my guest.
-I know, but that's, you know.
So you got to do
what your guests say.
-All right.
[ Laughs ]
-If you make this --
if you make this...
-Come on, man.
[ Grunts ]
[ Audience "Aws" ]
There's nothing to it.
That was awful.
I wanted you to go first.
That's why I...
Skyhook?!
[ Laughter ]
-That was close, though!
-All right, all right.
Here we go. Now we're warmed up.
-We're warmed up now.
This I don't even understand.
Why -- Why...?
-I have no idea
what to do or how to do it.
Maybe you can go, maybe --
Maybe...no.
-Oh!
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-That close.
-Taking it easy on me. I see.
-I don't know how the heck
you're gonna get this --
you just gotta throw it
really high.
[ Audience "Aws" ]
-[ Indistinct ]
That's right.
Now you're getting warmed up.
There we go.
-All right.
-All right. Cranberry sauce.
Here we go.
-Oh, this ain't gonna be --
this ain't gonna be...
-[ Laughs ]
Happy to have you.
Why are you backing away?
Happy Thanksgiving, dude.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can we see a replay on that?
-Slow motion?
-Yeah.
[ Audience "Aws" ]
-Very -- Ooh!
-Oh, he scored! It went in!
-Does that give --
they're gonna say yes.
They're gonna give me the point
on that one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Go for it. Go for it.
-I don't think I can top that.
-You can do it.
-Can I do a layup?
No, no. That might be...
[ Laughter ]
That might be --
-No, I don't want you to slip.
Go like -- you can do this too.
You can go underhand.
Whatever you think.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm done! I'm done!
I'm done!
-What?
-I'm done!
-I'm done.
-What?
Look at that thing.
-I told y'all.
-Can we see it again?
[ Cheering ]
-This is what I do.
-Now he's getting cocky.
What's the song y'all did?
It's all in the music.
-Here we go.
-It's all in the music.
-Legal, legal documents.
-Legal documents.
Uh-oh.
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is up?
♪♪♪♪
Yeah! Look at this.
This is a winner. This is
what a winner looks like.
Look at me. Look at me.
Just please look at me.
-You know, you know.
[ Laughter ]
You know you have
one of those --
you ever have those moments
when you're like, "Where am I?"
[ Laughter ]
You know, like suddenly
I just went, "What in the...?
We're sitting here
throwing skateboards
and he made it!"
-All right, good luck.
-Oh, it's light.
-Yeah, yeah, you can do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What is going on around here?
Here we go.
I hurt my wrist a little bit
on that last --
I think I'm going to need
someone to take my next shot.
Please welcome the point guard
for the NBA champion
Golden State Warriors,
Steph Curry.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪♪♪
-All right, all right,
all right.
-All right, Denzel --
-Wait a minute,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
-It's really him.
It's really him.
That's right, exactly.
Denzel, you go first.
-No, out of respect,
I wanna let the young buck...
-You gonna let me go first?
-...go first.
And now, if he makes this --
wait a minute, wait a minute,
wait a minute, wait a minute.
Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait.
-You gotta be careful because
there's cranberries everywhere.
-Watch yourself.
-Cranberries.
So, I want to give him
a chance to warm up.
Now don't -- if he makes this --
if he makes this,
he's gonna make it too, watch.
-What did y'all do
to the basket though?
[ Laughter ]
-That's a long story.
That's a long story.
It's a long story.
You just have to watch.
-He's gonna make it,
he's gonna make it.
-This is a warm up.
-Warm up? All right.
-Yeah, this one
doesn't even count.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-See? See?
-He did that like that
like that was nothing, dude.
-That's what I'd be telling
actors when they show up.
Like they think,
"Oh, I can act with you, D."
I'm like, "Okay, buddy."
[ Laughter ]
-And you just go up --
-Nothing to it.
-I know better.
-Yeah, you know better.
-Oh, we still gotta do one more.
-We still gotta do this.
-All right, I'll go first.
No pressure.
-Where is he going?
[ Laughter ]
-There's a line.
-Right here.
-My pants are falling down.
[ Laughter ]
You know, crack kills.
-No, no, no, Denzel!
-You got this.
-You guys know what you're
talking about, right?
-Cash.
-Oh.
-No, 'cause yours
was in the way.
-I told you, you gotta --
-You got blocked.
-What is this?
I've never seen one of these.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I'm just...
[ Laughs ]
-Wow, that's cold.
-Steph, do you think
you can you make that guy?
-Wait a minute, let me make it
easy for him.
[ Light laughter ]
No, make him -- I was gonna say,
make him go left.
-I love going left.
-Make him go right.
Make him go right.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-Steph Curry right there!
Denzel Washington!
The champ.
[ Cheers and applause ]
More "Tonight Show"
after the break, everybody.
Watch that replay of me again.